nous avons voulu évoquer un problème qui
même s'il a toujours existé reste un
mystère le transsexualisme peut-on être
en effet femme dans la peau d'un homme
ou l'inverse victime d'une erreur de la
nature comme l'affirment les
transsexuels souvent assimilés au
travesti les transsexuels suscite
toujours à malaise qui les
exclut
Simone alors nous nous nous connaissons
euh toutes les deux depuis depuis très
longtemps maintenant puisque nous avons
fait un film ensemble il y a quelques
quelques années et vous aussi au cours
de ce film vous parliez énormément du
rejet alors avant que vous n'apportiez
vous-même votre témoignage je vous
propose que nous regardions un extrait
de ce film qui s'appelait d'ailleurs qui
était intitulé prostitution et qui
s'appelait
travestir vous appelez comment
Simon et
avant j'ai du mal à me rappeler
mon prénom de baptême ou ils se sont
trompés c'était
[Musique]
al dans ma tête et sur mon frond j'ai
toujours eu le
sexe que je
souhaitais
[Musique]
c'estd
vous vous considérez comme quoi travesti
transsexuel trsexuel
transsexuel vous êtes opéré travesti ça
veut dire se déguiser je me déguise pas
je vis depuis 30 ans comme
ça vous êtes opéré
non j'ai eu des amis transsexuels qui
qui ont vu la transsexualité c'est un
ce n'est et l'opération n'est que
l'aboutissement de cet
état la société n'est déjà pas fait pour
l'être humain soi-disant
normal tellement de N normaux s sentent
mal comment pouvz vous pensez que pour
nous on est préparé quelque chose
rien nous sommes considéré Mo des
chiens voà Simon c'était un témoignage
dur sans appel est-ce que est-ce que
pour vous aussi ça a changé aujourd'hui
par rapport à il y a 30 ans ça a changé
pour les autres je suis très heureuse et
très fière de leur témoignage à celle
que je considère comme une sœur de
parcours parce qu'à la base il y a les
bê
il y a les mêmes choses même si elles
ont fait comme disait MAE dans son livre
mode marin le saut de l'ange je n'ai pas
voulu le faire comme je l'ai dit dans
reportage puisque j'ai eu très peur j'ai
eu des amis qui ont eu des problèmes de
santé très graves une est resté sur la
table d'opération à
Casablanca et je me suis dit ma petite
mmère regarde-toi dans une glace et puis
est-ce que ça va vraiment arranger les
choses
çaarrange les choses pour beaucoup
d'êtres pas pour tous je crois est-ce
que vous en avez souffert justement de
ne pas passer à l'acte il suffit de
regarder mes yeux
Mireille et puis c'est une souffrance de
tous les
jours jusqu'à la fin de toute façon
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que le
regard de la société a changé sur les
transsexuels est-ce qu'il y a davantage
de compréhension non je ne pense pas non
en surface peut-être à cause des médias
à cause des nombreuses émissions qui qui
sont passées à la télévision des
articles dans les journaux tout ça mais
peut-être plus àite de sensationnalisme
que de vraiment de vraie compréhension
humaine et de dimension humanistes et
dans ce pays où paraît-il les droits de
l'homme sont défendus que sommes-nous
nous si ce n'est des êtres humains qui
avont aussi des droits ne serait-ce que
le droit de pouvoir respirer avec
dignité al monsieur le ministre kayavet
vous vous avez été trois fois ministre
je le rappelle sénateur député et je
crois que c'est lorsque vous étiez
sénateur d'ailleurs que vous avez fait
une proposition de loi oui en 82
pourquoi justement à un moment donné
vous vous êtes intéressé à la
transsexualité au transsexualisme par
suite d'un événement singulier j'étais
sénateur j'ai reçu une demande présentée
par un sexuel qui voulait s'exprimer en
toute indépendance il savait que j'avais
fait et fait déposer pivoter le texte
sur la greffe d'organe que j'avais
conduit le débat pour les homosexuels
donc il pensait que je pouvais être à
son écoute et de fait quand je l'ai
accueilli j'ai été épouvanté parce que
cet homme ou cette femme s'était
gravement mutilée
elle s'était mutilée parce qu'elle
rejetait son sexe je l'ai accueilli
plusieurs fois elle m'a présenté
d'ailleurs deux autres personnes avec
lesquelles j'ai eu de longues
conversations je ne suis pas
psychanalyste mais j'ai quand même fait
licence de philosophie avec le
professeur Jean kellevic et comme j'ai
fréquenté Jean Rosan Jean Rosan disait
que la volupté féminine et la virilité
masculine dépendait d'un alcool stérol
qui était quasiment identique dans un
cas comme dans l'autre donc beaucoup de
d'humilité lorsqu'on aborde un tel débat
et j'ai donc entendu ces personnes qui
souffraient d' temp ment et ce qu'elle
cherchait c'est de se retrouver je dis
bien se retrouver parce qu'elle s'était
perdu et la société il faut bien le dire
n'est pas indulgente tout à l'heure l'un
d'entre vous a dit aujourd'hui nous
vivons dans les mêmes conditions
qu'autre fois vous avez raison lorsque
j'ai abordé le tabou de la mort puisque
moi je suis favorable à l'euthanasie
comme j'en ressant j'ai été rejeté par
la communauté législative c'estd par le
Parlement mais j'ai été
insulté par la presse lorsque j'ai
abordé la greffe d'organe on m'a traité
de d'épaisseur dans les cimetières de
charlatan que sais-je encore lorsque
j'ai abordé alors le débat sur
l'homosexualité on me dis oui mais toi
HRI aayavet tu peux en parler tu es un
passionné de rugby tu es virile tu es un
montagnard oui oui toi ça ne te gêne pas
à quoi je pensais que les autres étaient
gênés pourquoi l'homosexualité est un
état que je constate je suis hétéro
peut-être j'aurais dû être homo ou bisex
je sais rien en je l'ai pas été c'est
peut-être un regret cétait très tard
beaucoup trop tard bien que vous savez à
82 ans on peut permettre encore beaucoup
d'exp oui parce que je pas j'avais
oublié de donner votre âge effectivement
c'est c'est assez étonnant non mais je
le pouvoir de m'indigner et le pouvoir
d'imaginer et donc j'ai espéré
convaincre le Président P qui m'a dit
non tu viens de sortir du débat sur les
homosexuels maintenant tu avez les
transsexuels il n'en est plus question
et c'est parce que jeai pas l'accord de
monsieur le Président qui par ailleurs
m'a toujours soutenu dans les dans la
défense des minorités que ce débat n'a
plus venir est-ce qu'il viendra
jeoserai répondre par l'affirmative cou
la parole il y est moi ma patronne c'est
saint Rita la patronne des causes
désespéré et dans le monde politique
français excusez-moi de faire la
comparaison vous êtes la sain
Rita du monde politique français parce
que vous avez eu le courage vous et je
n'ose pas aller plus loin dans la
vulgarité de dire ce que vous ressentiez
et de défendre justement toujours les
minorités et d'aller contre eux le la
pensée généraliste et ça on ne l'avait
pas encore dit vous avvez entendu
beaucoup de choses mais je le prend je
le prends comme un compliment comme un
compliment exactement mais il me reste
plus qu'à devenir sain mais le plus tard
possible parce que je tiens pas à mourir
tout au moins tant que la loi ne sera
pas voté alors très franchement je crois
qu'en l'état le à cause des pressions
qui sont exercées en particulier par
l'Église par des lobbies il faut bien le
dire des lobbies ou des sectes ce débat
sur le transsexualisme est très
difficile à aborder dans nos villages un
inverti est rejeté il est moqué on ne
l'accepte pas il est de bon temps de
faire des jeux de mots et se comporter
avec esprit qui d'ailleurs est dérisoire
donc nous sommes en présence une société
bloquée qui a peur du sexe c'est un
tabou qui a peur de la mort c'est un
autre tabou et pour essayer de faire
progresser précisément la philosophie de
l'action législative nous sommes
confrontés à d'énormes difficultés pour
ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne Ina
Mireille Guma abonnez-vous et activez la
[Musique]
cloche